for whiny liberals 2017 was the longest
year ever but for us 2017 was the
longest year ever and nothing's gonna
stop us with only a few weeks left in
Trump's first year I'm at his final 2017
rally in Pensacola to talk to his fans
about all the incredible things he's
been able to accomplish favorite Trump
accomplishments 2017 favorite one is
probably the appointment of Neil Gorsuch
to the Supreme Court we got a travel ban
recognition of Jerusalem as the Israeli
capital basically draining the swamp we
are having a conversation about sexual
misconduct in this country we've never
had it before because they had we're now
having this beep no it is because of him
we're having this conversation somebody
had to go out there grab somebody by the
so we could talk about right
somebody had to grab somebody by the
balls so we can talk about it right well
I think what the I'm just saying
know that we show we're just saying
hashtag me too Trump is responsible for
sexual assault being part of the
national conversation but his enemies
don't want to give the man credit
[Music]
biggest villain of 2017 oh I'll say
Hillary Clinton I would say the swamp
the fake news media like CNN ABC CBS and
anybody else that doesn't share your
worldview if you want to just shout out
right now anybody would die school with
my man right here knows what it's all
about show us know this right here it is
the real tight news
we know the fake news is real nailed it
nailed it
zip it up though it's cold you know it
again yeah this is all normal though
it's like we've torn down all the
institutions we're like animals we don't
trust anything anymore
we could be fed anything thanks to trump
distrusting the news has been normalized
also thanks to trump I now know what
normalized means what else has Donald
Trump normalized he has actually
normalized this okay to be a Christian I
come from a Christian background so
definitely like something that's good
for me because like now we get to
actually you celebrate like Christmas
and stuff you weren't celebrating
Christmas before that we do but like
it's like Christmas like it's not you
like wouldn't get each other gifts
oh we do that too what were you doing
you're like saying about having holidays
and other people oh and that was
offensive thing yeah it's not offensive
I'm like you didn't really it wasn't
even really an issue no it was you feel
good about now that you can do yeah now
it's like he's just like okay it's
Christmas and I was like okay we could
feel good that it's Christmas
exactly even if we never felt any
different before right it's still an
issue that we can claim victory right
exactly if you can find a win and
something you kind of make up yeah
everything's a win when it's for America
Constitution Bill of Rights yeah
a flag I could word associate with her
for hours and I will stars there but
enough of that next year is just around
the corner and the haters are gonna
challenge Trump at every turn
what do you think the challenge in 2018
are gonna be North Korea it's got to be
on top of the list Russia Russia Russia
yeah where is the beef how about that
where's the beef any more things from
the 80s or 90s you want a reference all
right inna I think is gonna be more
opposition to the Daily Show
the Rory more situation to be
challenging and still continue into the
new year do you have an issue with Roy
Moore no I don't he's a man of God and
so definitely like I don't believe
anything that anyone says about that
like I suppose you don't believe that
nobody the women no and I'm not like
downing any of the women that have
actually been sexually assaulted
wait is that isn't that exactly what
we're doing no it's not I'm not saying
like Oh like no no it's a very like
serious issue and I don't there's under
no circumstance read out that sense
definitely but you think about Roy Moore
it's like honestly seen him as a type of
you doubt it yeah so but I don't want to
be one of those people who just doubt
women because exactly I'm not trying to
do that and there's such a fine line
between it's like it's a part of the
line okay so if it affects the person
I'm rooting for it's like that then I
know where I stay right exactly yeah
well we get the biggest challenge that
he faces in my opinion is unity for the
country we all have to lay our cards on
the table and just kind of respect
people for who they are we're going to
normalize unity in this country in 2018
big hope for 2018 what is it just more
unified America we should all come
together Democrats or Republicans this
is not about division is about unity and
getting things done that's right for the
country hey you were Trump man with 2017
coming to the
unity is on a lot of people's mind
here's the unified America it's
inspiring and as I watched the last
Trump supporters trickle in it occurs to
me maybe there is hope for us in the new
year all we have to do is come together
respect one another and engage in
thoughtful dialogue so we can finally
move forward as a nation our chance at
immunity
[Music]
[Applause]